♪
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP
ATTACKING DEMOCRATS AFTER A
HIGH STAKES HEARING ON
CAPITOL HILL.
ACTING DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE JOSEPH MAGUIRE
TESTIFYING ON THE
WHISTLEBLOWER COMPLAINT
AFTER IT WAS MADE PUBLIC.
THE WHISTLEBLOWER ACCUSING
THE WHITE HOUSE OF PUTTING A
TRANSCRIPT OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S CALL ON A SEPARATE
COMPUTER SYSTEM.
MOSTLY USED FOR CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
HERE'S CHAIRMAN ADAM SCHIFF
CLASHING WITH THE DIRECTOR.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IT HAS
CORROBORATED BY OTHER FOLKS.
THE WHISTLEBLOWER SAYS THAT
HE SPOKE OR SHE SPOKE TO
ABOUT A DOZEN OTHER PEOPLE.
THIS IS SECOND HAND
INFORMATION.
>> YOU MADE THE DECISION TO
WITHHOLD IT FROM THE
COMMITTEE FOR A MONTH.
>> AT NO TIME WAS THERE ANY
INTENT ON MY PART, SIR, EVER
TO WITHHOLD THE INFORMATION.
>> BUT WOULD YOU AGREE THAT.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
INVESTIGATION.
>> YOU AGREE THERE SHOULD BE
AN INVESTIGATION?
>> I BELIEVE THAT IT IS A
MATTER TO BE DETERMINED BY
THE CHAIR AND THIS
COMMITTEE.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP
RESPONDING AFTER THE
HEARING.
>> IT'S ANOTHER WITCH-HUNT.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
IT'S ADAM SCHIFF AND HIS
CREW MAKING UP STORIES.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
LOSE THE ELECTION.
THEY KNOW IT.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE DOING
IT.
MY CALL WAS PERFECT.
THE PRESIDENT YESTERDAY OF
UKRAINE SAID THERE WAS NO
PRESSURE PUT ON HIM
WHATSOEVER.
WHAT THESE GUYS ARE DOING,
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING TO THIS
COUNTRY IS A DISGRACE.
AND IT SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED.
NANCY PELOSI HAS BEEN
HIJACKED BY THE RADICAL LEFT
AND EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
>> Dana: ANOTHER MOMENT
THAT'S GETTING A LOT OF
ATTENTION AND A DOOSIE.
ADAM SCHIFF CREATING
CONTROVERSY AFTER
MISCHARACTERIZING TRUMP'S
CALL WITH THE UKRAINE
PRESIDENT.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY THIS
ONLY SEVEN TIMES SO YOU
BETTER LISTEN GOOD.
I WANT TO YOU MAKE UP DIRT
ON MY POLITICAL OPPONENT,
UNDERSTAND LOTS OF IT.
AND BY THE WAY DON'T CALL ME
A AGAIN.
I WILL CALL YOU WHEN YOU
HAVE DONE WHAT I ASKED.
THIS IS IN SUM AND CHARACTER
WHAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
TRYING TO COMMUNICATE.
>> Dana: SCHIFF LATER
CLAIMING IT WAS JUST A
PARODY BUT GREG, AREN'T
PARODIES SUPPOSED TO BE
FUNNY?
>> Greg: APPARENTLY THAT ONE
WASN'T.
CAN WE GET A SINGLE SHOT OF
DANA REALLY QUICK?
DOESN'T SHE LOOK LIKE A
SECRET AGENT FROM DANDY
ALAN?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: YOU ARE RIGHT.
ADAM SCHIFF OPENINGS UP BY
MAKING UP PASSAGES ON
TRANSCRIPT AND CONTRIBUTING
IT TO TRUMP'S VOICE.
WHEN HE IS CAUGHT HE SAYS OH
THIS IS A PARODY.
SOME PEOPLE THAT PARS OVER
TRUMP'S WORDS.
IF THE TRANSCRIPT WAS TRULY
DAMAGING, HE WOULDN'T HAVE
NEEDED TO MAKE UP ANYTHING.
HE TRULY IS FULL OF SCHIFF.
[LAUGHTER]
ABOUT THIS COMPLAINT SO THE
MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS ARE
EMBRACING SECOND-HAND GOSSIP
OVER AN ACTUAL TRANSCRIPT.
THEY
THERE ARE LIKE 20 VARIATIONS
OF THE GUY SAYING I WAS
TOLD.
THE MEDIA SIGHTS
THE MEDIA SITHTS
THE MEDIA SITESS
THE MEDIA SITES AS EVIDENCE
MEDIA.
THEY CITE POLITICO.
ABC, GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS.
COMPLAINT IS A MIXTURE OF
HEARSAY, FALSEHOODS, MEDIA
CLIPPINGS.
BASICALLY THE STEELE DOSSIER
LESS PEEING AND MORE LYING.
THEY REALIZE THEY COULDN'T
BEAT THE TRANSCRIPT BECAUSE
THOSE FACTS GO AGAINST THEIR
STORY.
FINALLY, I WANT TO ADDRESS
THE BOMBSHELL THAT EVERYBODY
IS TALKING ABOUT.
THE LOCKDOWN.
THE TIGHTER RESTRICTIONS ON
THE TRANSCRIPT.
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
DO YOU THINK IT MAY BE
BECAUSE TWO YEARS AGO PEOPLE
WERE LEAKING TRANSCRIPTS
FROM THE LEADER'S
CONVERSATIONS WITH MEXICO
AND AUSTRALIA SO THINK WERE
PUTTING THIS STUFF IN A
SEPARATE CODE WORD SYSTEM
BECAUSE IT WAS BEING LEAKED.
DOESN'T THAT KIND OF MAKE
SENSE ESPECIALLY WHEN TRUMP
RELEASES THE TRANSCRIPT WHY
WOULD YOU RELEASE SOMETHING
YOU WERE HIDING?
IT WASN'T ABOUT TRYING TO
HIDE SOMETHING.
IT WAS ABOUT TRYING TO
PROTECT SOMETHING FROM BEING
BEING LEAKED.
THAT IS COMMON SENSE.
WHEN YOU ARE FLOODED WITH
COGNITIVE BIAS YOU CAN'T SEE
THE SENSE.
CAN YOU ONLY SEE WHAT YOU
WANT TO BELIEVE.
>> Dana: ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY SAY THIS IS A PRACTICE
WE STARTED AFTER THAT.
IF THEY WERE TO SAY THAT
THAT WOULD CERTAINLY HELP
THEM.
AND TO YOUR POINTED ABOUT
THE COMPLAINT AND SECOND
HAND KNOWLEDGE, A LAWYER I
TALKED TO TODAY, JESSE, SAID
THIS DOCUMENT WOULD BE
INADMISSIBLE IN A COURT OF
LAUGH BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED HEARSAY AND NO
JUDGE WOULD ALLOW IT.
>> Jesse: WELL, I READ THE
COMPLAINT AND IT READS LIKE
A THRILLER NOVEL AND IT
READS LIKE IT WAS
PROFESSIONALLY TEED UP BY
CONSPIRACY INSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE TRYING TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT DESTROYED THEM.
REMEMBER THE CONTEXT ABOUT
THIS.
BILL BARR, DURHAM, AND THESE
INVESTIGATORS ARE ABOUT TO
BLOW UP THE ENTIRE SPY GATE
CABAL.
THEY ARE ABOUT TO NAME
NAMES.
AND THIS WHOLE THING IS
ABOUT TO UNRAVEL.
SO, BEFORE THEY DO, THIS IS
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
AGAIN STRIKING BACK AT BILL
BARR AND DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IS WARFARE NOW.
BECAUSE, IF YOU READ THE
COMPLAINT, THIS IS STUFF
THAT IS SO DETAILED AND SO
COMPREHENSIVE AND SO
SOPHISTICATED AND COMING
FROM SO MANY DIFFERENT
SOURCES, SO MANY DIFFERENT
LEVELS, THIS HAS TO BE AN
ORGANIZED CABAL OF PEOPLE
INSIDE SELLING THIS GUY THE
BILL OF GOODS SO THEN HE
GIVES IT TO THE DEMOCRATS
BECAUSE IT READS LIKE A
THRILLER.
THIS DOESN'T COME OUT OF
THIN AIR.
AND THERE IS NO GUESSING WHY
BILL BARR IS SPECIFICALLY
NAMED IN THIS WHISTLEBLOWER
COMPLAINT.
AND IT'S BECAUSE THEY NEED
TO DISCREDIT HIM BEFORE THIS
THING IS RELEASED.
AND YOU ARE GOING TO HEAR,
ALSO, REQUESTS FOR HIM TO
RECUSE HIMSELF FROM NOT ONLY
THE UKRAINE INVESTIGATION
BUT ALSO THE SPY GATE
INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT.
THIS IS SICK.
AND IT'S NO COINCIDENCE THAT
ADAM SCHIFF IS RUNNING THIS
OPERATION AGAIN.
HE HAS BEEN TOTALLY
HUMILIATED.
REMEMBER, HE WAS ON A PHONE
CALL TRYING TO GET NAKED
PICTURES OF DONALD TRUMP IN
A PRANK PHONE CALL BEFORE
THAT WAS EXPOSED?
THE NETWORKS TOOK THIS LIVE
ALL DAY, INTERRUPTED REGULAR
PROGRAMMING.
HUGE MISTAKE.
THE THING HAD NO ENERGY.
AND, REMEMBER, THIS GUY ADAM
SCHIFF WAS THE ONE THAT SAID
HE HAD PROOF THAT THERE WAS
RUSSIA COLLUSION.
AND HE NEVER PRODUCED IT.
NOW HE IS SAYING HE HAS
PROOF THAT THERE IS A QUID
PRO QUO.
HE STILL HAS NOT PRODUCED
IT.
SO NOW HE HAS TO FABRICATE
QUOTES TO SELL THIS THING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE BECAUSE
HE CAN'T SELL IT ON THE
SUBSTANCE.
>> Dana: JUAN, SPEAKER
PELOSI HAD A PRESS
CONFERENCE AT 11:00 A.M. AND
SHE FLAT OUT SAID DNI BROKE
THE LAW.
THE DEMOCRATS THINK THIS IS
A VERY GOOD DAY FOR THEM.
DO YOU?
>> Juan: I DO THINK IT WAS A
VERY GOOD DAY, DANA.
THE REASON THEY THINK IT'S A
GOOD DAY LET'S GET BACK TO
THE HEART OF THE STORY.
BASICALLY THE WHISTLEBLOWER
COMPLAINT WAS BACKED UP BY
THE TRANSCRIPT RELEASED
YESTERDAY.
WHAT THE WHISTLEBLOWER HAD
TO SAY, AGAIN, CONFIRMS ALL
THAT WE READ YESTERDAY IN
THE TRANSCRIPT AND THE IDEA
OF THE LOCKDOWN, THERE WAS
NO NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE
HERE.
NONE.
>> Greg: HOW ABOUT THE
FACTS.
>> Juan: IT WAS ABOUT
POLITICS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE
PROTECTING.
IN ADDITION, ACCORDING TO
THE WHISTLEBLOWER, YOU HAVE
LAWYERS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
WHO ARE SAYING YOU KNOW, WE
HAD SEVERAL OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE PUT
INTO THIS SECRET SYSTEM.
THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
PROTECTING THIS PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: FROM LEAKING.
>> Juan: OWN POLITICAL
DAMAGE.
AND SO WHEN YOU GET TO THAT
POINT, YOU START TO WONDER
WHAT ELSE IS GOING ON INSIDE
THIS WHITE HOUSE.
>> Jesse: CITING ANONYMOUS
SOURCES FROM THE "THE
WASHINGTON POST."
>> Juan: NO I'M NOT.
>> Jesse: YES, YOU ARE.
WHO TOLD YOU THAT?
>> Juan: I SAID THE
WHISTLEBLOWER.
>> Jesse: WHO WAS TOLD BY
SOMEONE ELSE.
>> Juan: CORRECT.
>> Jesse: SO THAT'S HEARSAY.
>> Juan: EVERYTHING HE HAS
SAID HAS BEEN BACKED UP.
>> Jesse: NOT TRUE.
>> Juan: IDEA INTERFERING
FOR THE FOREIGN COUNTRY FOR
THE 2020 ELECTION.
>> Jesse: ISN'T THAT WHAT
OBAMA AND HILLARY DID, JUAN?
>> Greg: DID TRUMP ASK FOR
THE SERVERS BACK?
>> Juan: THIS IS THE
GATEWAY, ISN'T IT BECAUSE
THEY WERE AFRAID OF JOE
BIDEN.
THEY WANT TO DEMONIZE JOE
BIDEN JUST LIKE THAT WAS THE
GAME PLAN TO GO AFTER
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Katie: THEY ARE AFRAID
THAT JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO
TAKEN OUT AND TRUMP IS GOING
TO RUN AGAINST ELIZABETH
WARREN AND WIN.
THEY THINK JOE BIDEN IS THE
BEST PERSON TO TAKE HIM ON
IN SWING STATES LIKE
PENNSYLVANIA, WISCONSIN,
MICHIGAN, ET CETERA.
BUT, ONE THING I THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
CONTINUE POINTING OUT.
I TALKED TO A COUPLE OF
PEOPLE TODAY WHO DEAL WITH
WHISTLEBLOWER COMPLAINTS
ABOUT THE SIDE OF RECEIVING
COMPLAINTS AND PUTTING ON
PROTECTIONS FOR PEOPLE WHO
ISSUE THESE CLAIMS.
AND THEY SAID THAT IT IS
HIGHLY UNUSUAL THAT A CLAIM
WITH SECOND OR THIRD HAND
KNOWLEDGE WOULD EVER BE
CONSIDERED SOMETHING THAT
WAS LEGITIMATE BECAUSE
SPECIFICALLY THE LAW
PROTECTS PEOPLE WITH FIRST
HAND KNOWLEDGE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
COMPLAINT, THERE ARE
MULTIPLE REFERENCES TO A
NUMBER OF WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS WHO TOLD ME X.
WELL, IF THAT IS THE CASE
AND IF IT IS SO EGREGIOUS
THAT IT REQUIRES EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE TO BE WAIVED AND
FOR THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
AND THE FBI TO GET INVOLVED,
THOSE WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS
HAVE THE PROTECTIONS TO
PRESENT THIS INFORMATION
FIRSTHAND.
AND THE OTHER BIG THING IS
THAT WAS DETAILED TODAY BY
THE ACTING DNI CHIEF IS THAT
CONGRESS WOULDN'T HAVE
GOTTEN THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY HAVE WITH THE COMPLAINT
BEING RELEASED IF PRESIDENT
TRUMP HADN'T RELEASED THE
TRANSCRIPT OF THE CALL
BECAUSE IT GOT RID OF THE
CLASSIFICATION AND IT GOT
RID OF THE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
AND SO THE ONLY REASON WHY
CONGRESS GOT THIS IS BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT WAS
TRANSPARENT IN DOING AN
UNPRECEDENTED MOVE AND
RELEASING THIS CALL AND REST
OF THE COUNTRY HAS BEEN ABLE
TO READ THIS COMPLAINT AND
TO WHAT YOU SAID, IT IS NOT
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE
TRANSCRIPT SAYS THERE IS A
LOT IN THE COMPLAINT THAT
DOESN'T ADD UP TO -- AND THE
NUMBER OF TIMES BIDEN WAS
MENTIONED.
>> Juan: THE REASON IS NOT
BECAUSE OF DONALD TRUMP.
THE REASON IT CAME OUT IS
BECAUSE SOMEBODY HAD THE
HEART, HAD THE STRENGTH TO
SAY I'M GOING TO BE A
WHISTLEBLOWER AND PUT MY
CAREER AT RISK IN ORDER TO
SAVE THIS COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: JUAN, CAN WE
ESTABLISH IN ORDER TO MOVE
THE CONVERSATION ALONG
BECAUSE WE WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT THIS FOR A VERY LONG
TIME.
>> Juan: OKAY.
>> Jesse: WOULD YOU CONCEDE
THAT THE DEMOCRATS WERE
SUSPICIOUS OF SOMETHING
DONALD TRUMP DID WRONG
DURING THE LAST ELECTION AND
THEY USED FOREIGN COUNTRY'S
HELP AND FOREIGN ASSETS TO
HELP THEM INVESTIGATE DONALD
TRUMP AND HIS ASSOCIATES?
>> Juan: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN'T ADMIT TO
THAT WE CAN'T HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION.
>> Juan: YOU THINK FUSION
GPS IS A FOREIGN.
>> Jesse: HARD GUY
INVESTIGATE THIS STUFF.
>> Juan: HARD NEWS.
>> Jesse: PUT YOUR HARD NEWS